hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast validation and implementation
of whole exome sequencing to guide
precision cancer care
I am Brenda Kelly Kim lab routes and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
routes the leading social networking
site for science professionals for more
information please visit
www.dent.umich.edu/license as we can
today you can enlarge the slide window
by clicking on the screen icon in the
lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you have any technical
problems viewing or hearing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation window
or submit your problem through the green
Q&A button lower left let's get right to
it I would now like to introduce today's
speaker dr. Hannah Renner dr. Renner is
an assistant professor of pathology and
Laboratory Medicine at Weill Medical
College of Cornell University and
director of the molecular pathology
laboratory at the New York Presbyterian
Hospital she received her PhD
biochemistry from the Technion Israel
Institute of Technology medical school
following postdoctoral training at the
University of Pennsylvania dr. Rennick
served in oversight roles with the
molecular pathology lab in the
department of pathology and Laboratory
Medicine dr. Rennicks primary research
interest is the genetic epidemiology of
prostate cancer a second research
interest is the development of clinical
molecular tests and applications her
current efforts as the director of
molecular pathology laboratory and NY
phw CMC are focused on expanding the
molecular pathology
test menu particularly in virology
genetics and n ecology specific tests
under development include quantification
assays for the herpes viruses including
real-time PCR pharmacogenetic testing
and EGFR Ras mutation analysis in
addition collaboration with clinicians
and researchers at rogue roastin
Institute dr. Rennicks group has
developed and implemented a new strategy
to screen from mutations and the
polycystic kidney disease one and two
genes using a mismatch specific DNA
endonuclease I will now turn it over to
dr. Renard for her presentation good
afternoon and thank you Belinda Saudia
introduction today I will be talking to
you about validation and implementation
of whole exome sequencing testing they
are so precision cancer kills so why do
we want to sequence the cancer genome
with NGS the method is high so put it
can test many genes at once it's
systematic and it's unbiased method for
detection of many types of mutations
including Smith's indels and copy number
alterations
it can identify most of all somatic
mutation in a tumor it can identify
tumor subtypes
for example her2 positive breast cancer
it can identify targeted somatic
alterations for example EGFR mutation in
non small cell lung cancer
it allowed discovery of new ways to
target tumor cells and it's a
cost-effective precision medicine care
with the right drug the idols to the
right patient at the right time this is
an example of a patient diagnosed with
metastatic non-small cell lung cancer at
age 53 the patient is never smoking it
was diagnosed with
of that did not improve with antibiotics
a chest CT showed a mass like
consolidation with speculated margin and
the Antillean right lower low but you
could you could see on the left genetic
testing has an identified an EGFR
mutation and he has been started on
chemotherapy followed by a lot in nib to
control his metastatic disease to the
lung as well as metastatic disease to
skeletal regions city performed several
months later showed an excellent tumor
response to the drugs and decreased
tumor size as you can see here in the
NGS data igv shows you the lesion of
excellent sequence in the lesion of exon
19 sequences in EGFR and the
corresponding sample sequence below the
solid line in igv corresponds to the
deletion 19 sequences that has been
identified relative to the resolution
and the arrow in the sandal sequencing
in the electropherogram below row
represents the first nucleotide of that
deletion unfortunately and you can see
India India in India on the right track
city showed increasing density in the
right lower and upper lung lobe lessons
most likely representing resistance to a
lotta nib and the NGO studies indeed
confirmed that the patient has a new
resistance mutation the t7 90 M so now
in the last decades increasing evidence
regarding the utility and benefits of
genomic medicine prompted with President
Barack Obama to outline an ambition
vision of medical research hoping that
this becomes the foundation
of a new era of revolutionize medicine
and this year during the White House
precision medicine initiative last month
he actually asked the Congress for
another 300 million dollars to scale up
the initiative and almost all of it for
the NIH however this new initiative has
also generated sub-state substantial and
debate in the public and press
questioning whether the enthusiasm over
genome sequencing is metal in medicine
is overblown the main concern raised in
a recent debate in the New York Times
here that yet you can see is that lab
tests do not work as advertised
application of genomic based era P 2d
applied with Scotian data sharing
institution and reference lab do not
share data and finally the question of
health equity
well only people with higher education
good health insurance or good social
economical status can afford these
therapies so where what are the current
NGS tests that are used so in cancer
whether those are commercial or a lab
develop tests we use well-defined panel
with mutations known to affect ERT this
is also call it can be called hotspot
panel these panels are usually smaller
panel they can interrogate anywhere from
40 to 400 page in depending on the panel
and example so that will be the Illumina
to see cancer panel away and so many of
you are familiar with the amplification
panel by ion toiled this targeted tests
are typically very rapid they are highly
accurate but only a small number of
mutations can be
another report that is now more common
in genetics is using whole exome
sequencing which detects a wide range of
new of somatic mutation but this test
has lower sensitivity and longer turn on
time and we also have now a emerging
whole whole genome sequencing that can
analyze the entire team including
rearrangement and non-coding RNA but the
coverage is low and the procedure is
very time-consuming and still very
expensive probably five to ten fold more
than the whole exome sequencing
so while wise is widely used already in
clinical genetics it's only recently
that it started gaining adoption for
cancer care
here at our institution here institution
for precision medicine we chose to
develop the clinical whole exome
sequencing test for precision canceled a
care and the major goal is that it will
be high throughput cost effective with
optimal coverage and it also addresses
quality standards for the analytical
procedure as well as for the
bioinformatic analysis pipelines the
advantage of such a test are actually
numerals it can target clinical
actionable mutations in
clinically-relevant genes as well as
serve as a screening tool for other
important genetic variations and
mutation types it also allows detection
of germline mutation in cancer by
disposing genes and it allows detection
of incidental genes according to the
ACMG secondary finding recommendations
English and it can also allow the text
and of mutations in genes a effect
in therapy however a sequencing of
cancer journey of cancer genome and is
highly challenging cancel genomes are
extremely complex and diverse they have
a higher level of heterogeneity among
some types of cells there is a high
degree of variation in cancers and
themselves themselves compared to
essence or the normal genome there is a
- Matic variation in mutation type into
evidence and there is also variation in
copy number as well as ploidy and then
most tumors are really our new ployed
which require distinct computation and
analysis and finally this tumor also
have complex genomic structure changes
such as translocations in there other
rearrangements in addition there are
also challenges involving cancer samples
cancer samples vary in quantity quality
and purity for me germline DNA samples
the principal samples that is used here
is formalin-fixed paraffin-embedded
tissue that mostly integrated and
damaged DNA quantity is also an issue
because you can get biopsies that with
small amount of tissue or finally a
spirit samples and some as they do
require substantial amount of DNA also
as I said in terms of quality most
samples are formalin-fixed and currently
we have no standards for fixation for
molecular testing often sample include
necrotic tissue tissues or decalcified
and we also have admixture with normal
cells and this really requires the
pathology review to ensure that testing
is performed
DNA from tumor cells and we also have
the issue of heterogeneity of the cancer
itself that is comprised of different
clones that evolve over time
so while de strengths challenges are
well recognized and despite a wide range
of essays and platforms that are
available which has not been yet
validated for the clinical laboratory
and has not been fully characterized in
the literature with regard to its
analytical valid did with regard with
its analytical validity clinical testing
in the u.s. is overall regulated but but
by clear but clear does not provide
specific guidelines for testing or
validation in the few existing
professional guidelines given by the
American College of medical genetics the
College of American Pathologists and New
York State Department of Health give
only high-level direction for
implementing NGS testing which is geared
primarily how's the use of targeted
panel rather than a whole exome
sequencing now by all accounts New York
State Department of Health requirements
are among the most rigorous guidelines
he had published and are likely to serve
as a paradigm for a suggested type of
guidelines that might be required by the
FDA New York State's requirement for the
validation of mutation detection by NGS
over all follows the same basic
principles of validation of other
complex molecular diagnostic tests the
point simple analytical characteristic
includes overall accuracy sensitivity
and specificity of the si that same
has been it should be done first with
reference DNA to determine the error
rate across all target area analytical
sensitivity to establish the limit of
detection for each type of clinically
significant variant and this can be
first established with cell line but
then it needs to be verified with
patient samples precision in
reducibility should be done with patient
sample in replicates containing variant
next to the limit of detection of the SI
and then call stock validation to verify
there is no barcode crosstalk between
samples and that results our toward
usable New York State also require that
validation is performed by sample type
so if your test is using fresh tissue
blood bone marrow FMA FFP all of them
need to be validated and the initial
validation must include at least 50
patient samples and if you are going to
use s SPE so then 75 percent of the
samples had to be FFPE samples in
addition you should provide a minimum of
10 positive patient sample for each type
of variant and this needs to be included
and confirmed by an independent method
and that needs to be ideally a testing
that has been performed by a different
reference lab and then once the testing
is approved there is a requirement for
ongoing of the journal confirmation of
newly identified variants and gene up to
ten positives New York State also have
requirements about the standard
operating procedure
you see controls and more information
can be found in the link that I provided
here so to identify the whole exome
platform that can be the best platform
for the wise si
we initially evaluated by the different
exome capture technology it vary widely
in their design and library preparation
characteristics the five libraries where
the year Agilent hello clicks Agilent
show select Tosic from Illumina company
Moulton and the next paraffin Illumina
again and and for the evaluation library
with will derive for me 4050 tumor
samples according to each manufacturer
recommendations recommended protocol so
as you can see in this slide here with
the exception of the aluminum experiment
otology the average number of mapped
reads varied between 72 in 180 million
and the total number of which in caps
and regions also vary significantly
between 52% for a cap on in building to
90% for halo clicks now the read loss
was generally due to with mapped to non
target region with the halo click
showing the fewer storage that met to
off-site targets when we compared the
target coverage efficiency for the
selected technologies using
FFPE reference DNA horizon 1 and that's
a reference DNA that you can buy and
patient DNA the Agilent halo Plex
technology had an overall
two fold higher average coverage in
captured region air of 103 and 104 X
versus 31 x compared to copper nimble
genes while there was no significant
difference in the percentage of capital
bases covered the depth of at least an X
which was about 93 to 95 percent
as you can see here in the last column
and very high correlation between snip
allele frequencies was also observed
between Agilent and helioplex in Agilent
so select which is a different capture
method for base capture method but so
select requires consent considerably
higher amounts of DNA a one point five
mark in microgram versus 200 nano gram
and in addition which is very important
hello clicks performed equally well for
FFPE and non SS de DNA samples so based
on that we chose the high-low clicks
technology for our reliable required
hello clicks library covers over 350,000
exomes that correspond to more than
21,000 gene so a total of 36 made
Megabass of sequence for the studies we
used 2225 nanogram of say high molecular
weight genomic DNA and about 500 nano
gram of a FFPE DNA the library
preparation as you can see here included
4 major step the first step was a DNA
fragmentation by a restriction enzyme in
the second step DNA fragments were
hybridized to helical probes with
alumina sequences motif which allows
your correlations of the DNA in the next
step the DNA probe hybrids were ligated
to a magnetic base coated with sweat
avidin and then the targeted fragments
were amplified with PCR and then
following the enrichment
the Exim Library was loaded into a
Illumina HiSeq flow cell for a onboard
cluster generation shown on the right
annealing of sequencing primer was
followed by multiple amplification cycle
resulting in clustered clones of every
individual DNA molecule attached and
once this is accomplished the sequencing
primer were annealed to individual DNA
fragments to the shed a shell adapter
and the flow cell was there ready for
sequencing sequencing was then performed
on an Illumina HiSeq 2500 system using
100 base pair paired-end reads in
heighted mode which is four samples per
line for a total of 16 samples for two
flow cells and this takes about 24 hours
to completion so it's really the entire
process from a library motivation whoo
sequencing can take as little as 3 days
that it's much better than anything else
that we looked at at the time of
validation now for the validation of the
whole exome test we have followed New
York state guidelines for somatic
genetic variant detection as I mentioned
earlier and we have used have not
samples and reference material as well
as 57 matched normal and tumor DNA
samples as you can see here in this
diagram the overall sa analytical
characteristic was analyzed with
reference DNA material and clinical
sample the reportable range was
characterized with normal DNA and
verified with tumor
and the analytical sensitivity for a
specific mutation was performed using
mutation positive saline and then
verified with tumor sample next to the
limit of detection and the precision and
reproducibility was done with with the
clinical sample next to the limit of
detection of the sa so for the
validation process we focused on the
fight clinically relevant mutations or
genes that represented three different
types of variants single nucleotide
variants indels and copy number
alterations and you can see here the
five variants EGFR the 19 Kaos codons 12
and 13 mutations beavers v600e jak 2 v 6
1 7 F and her2 amplification in addition
we delimited validation for a panel of
49 cancer genes that were designated as
clinically significant so overall there
were over 300 samples used for that
validation this slides now summarizes
the EC metrics of the new si by sample
type you can see the average total
number of wait was similar between the
hapmap sample DNA and the clinical
sample with an overall average of 70
million reads any capture rate of 84
percent high-quality average of a
coverage of 86 and 1986 X and the 93 X
was obtained for the hapmap and clinical
samples respectively with at least 94
percent of the exome covered at more
than 10x
you can also see that we'd uncovered
statistics we were similar for
sequencing glance of library that were
propelled from sspe and known sspe
DNA samples and indicating that sspe
tissues are suitable for these engines
based analysis yeah as you can see in
these slides QC metrics adult you see
metrics including total reads percentage
of capture rates average coverage and
fraction of bases covered a 10x did not
differ significantly either by sample
type which you could see here on the
Left all by mutation positive samples
that we'll use for the analysis which is
here on the right and these samples well
obviously the clinical samples that we
used for the validation this really
means that there was no selection bias
in terms of the samples that were used
for the validation next we value - we
evaluated the accuracy of of this test
using the half of DNA na12878 which is a
commonly used DNA sample in this type of
studies so for this validation which was
done according to New York state
requirement germanized sequence
variation calls IDO homozygous and
heterozygous that were generated by our
PI time for the half of DNA while
analyzing duplicates and were compared
with the publicly available whole genome
reference materials according to socket
all of the 27 point 88 million sites 27
point eight six million sites were
called homozygous om reference site
negative while seventeen thousand nine
hundred and seventeen base pairs were
designated as not know a syringe valium
of the latest 773 variants of the
normalizer inside were not detected by
our SA which that was designated to be
false negative conversely there were
only 149 out of the 27 point 86 million
bases that were missed called as non
residents variance by exact one compared
to the reference benchmark so this
variance will be designated as false
positive this result estimated a
sensitivity specificity and positive
predictive value of 95.7% 99.9% and 99.9
percent for the positive predictive
value based on this data we could also
estimate the false discovery rate by
comparing variant calls from two
separate replicates of the hapmap DNA
and this was less than 1% and further
assessment of index crosstalk
demonstrated a total error rate of less
than point three percent which was far
below the limit of detection of fair our
assay with the next when to look at the
reportable range the reported reportable
range defined by a New York state
guideline as the genomic region in which
sequence of an acceptable quality can be
divided was determined as the unique
depth of coverage so each base position
of the Exim across the cohort of 4509
DNA controls these samples were expected
to have slow genomic complexity and they
also provide more accurate assessment of
coverage and performance statistics as
you can see here and in the table below
of the 77 million hello clicks exon
basis only 4.3 bases had less than 10x
covered for at least 36 out of the
fortified controls while less than 1% of
the bases were covered at less than 10x
across all 45 samples the poly covered a
4.3 genomic areas were excluded from our
reportable lines we then next validated
exact one focusing on the five principal
genes that we submitted to New York
State which are again EGFR we asked Jack
to hope to go to new and Kayla's using
both high molecular weight John 9 DNA
and the FFP DNA samples the diagram in
these slides show you coverage by gene
and by Exxon and the red box in each
graph indicates coverage by the exon
harboring mutation by gene and the blue
horizontal line which is above the
x-axis indicate depth coverage of 10x
you can see that really overall although
the so you can see two things one thing
is that coverage by Exxon within each
and every gene is highly variable and
then the other thing that you can see
that coverage within the germline DNA
is obviously more consistent than the
coverage within the FFPE DNA samples and
that likely is due to the poor quality
of the DNA samples now as I noted before
we also had to demonstrate limited
performance characteristics or the 49
gene designated as clinically actionable
and these genes are shown in this table
these genes have been selected based on
their significance in both solid tumors
and hematological malignancies this
figure shows the average covered by
clinically relevant gene because the
clinical validation samples each bar
plot shows the mean Facebook average by
gene across all the validation sample
and each row is a gene and the bar code
represents the distribution of the mean
coverage across all samples this metric
was calculated by dividing the total
coverage by the total number of coding
Spaceballs
and the red dash line red the red line
is actually the 30 extras hold and as
you can see overall for for the 50 genes
almost all samples are met this destroys
hold now to define better the regions
with lower coverage because obviously
they were like with some regions like
this based on the standard deviation
that you have seen we have also analyzed
the percentage of exonic regions below a
specific averaged a toehold represented
here by each column the colors represent
the percentage below a coverage
threshold
so for example the urban scholars shows
you that 80% of the coding region for
these genes are below ATX and so forth
the heat map of the corresponding data
showed actually that only a limited
percentage of basis protein did not
achieve the 30x unique average across
the validation sample but for the
majority of the gene only about 10 to
20% of the coding region were covered at
less than 10x air next we have examined
the the analytical sensitivity of the
essay for selected mutation using the
Aleutian studies the synthetic mix
samples were generated form a mutation
positive cell lines diluted into HobNob
DNA as determined by the Ion Torrent
amplify cancer assay and that for EGFR
care has be - jack - and by digital
droplet PCR for her2/neu copy number the
proportion of mutations for the delusion
studies ranged between 2 and 50% and all
experiments were performed in three
decades we have been using thus aligns
our user lines that have been purchased
from 88 ECC and all and so all of them
are publicly available as you can see
there was an excellent correlation
between the observed and expected
mutations allele frequency and also what
we saw that the threshold of our essay
for detecting variants at lower
frequency was established at 10% for
her2/neu on vegetation the copy number
threshold was established at
to ratio of thermal to normal normal of
point six which corresponds to above
three point five copies of her2/neu as
we assess by digital PCR assuming we are
using pure tumor samples now New York
state requires that sensitivity control
next to the limit of detection I'll
included in each and every assay this
video shows you the level Jenning charts
so representative sensitivity control
monitored within plus minus twenties and
plus minus 3s days the x axis displays
time of sequential on and the y axis
shows you the value of each sensitivity
control results the sensitivity control
targets are highlighted by the yellow
line so you could see that some
sensitivity control for example what we
have for GSR is really we are using a
target of 10 percent and so jack - we've
been using a target of 15 percent and
for how to new amplification with in
using look to where she of 1 is our
sensitivity control and also you can see
that data values overall demonstrated
consistent as a performance within the
allow allowable limits of measurement
error over time
finally false negative results are also
amazed a major concern especially when
you have a test like whole exome
sequencing except that does not have
coverage within the hundreds
so we profound power analysis to
determine the threshold so avoiding
false negative results at the VA s
threshold of 10 to 12 percent because
this is what
we confirmed to be the LOD of our si and
what this graph shows you that at this V
is at least 28 X total coverage is
needed for avoiding false negative
results if no mutation is present so
finally we will you could see that based
on this data we were able to put some
quality metrics for a mutation call so
for pointing patients indeed Sindel we
require minimal total a little count of
30 reads alternate a little count of at
least five rates and the minimal
alternate a little fraction of 10% we
also put together some some guidelines
for a copy number alteration and this is
really much more complicated so copy
number loss could be divided in two
heterozygote and homozygote which would
be more severe for heterozygote sauce
and the ratio of two more to log to
ratio of tomorrow to normal should be
higher than minus one and lower than
then minus point five so a copy number
loss which is homozygous that will be
determined if flock to ratio is their
equal or less than minus one for copy
number gain we also define the smaller
copy number gain versus allow them to
purses and amplifications of many copies
so a lock to ratio between point five
and the point eight will be counted as a
copy number games while amplification
should show a logo issue of point eight
now those log two ratios are all
adjusted by ploidy and to multi ot and
we are using some application called
clone 8 for this in addition to actually
estimate
of the neoplastic context i apologies
air finally we have been also looking at
some other mutation using a reference
material this is the horizon one
material reference material that has a
list of mutations with ranging allele
frequencies from like 1% to 26%
so when we did that we also we can see
that there was a great agreement between
between the calls by a horizon 1 and the
expected calls that have been received
using our test we also looked at the
ampliseq test at a bunch of mutation
that we received that we added analyzed
here in-house and we analyzed and by the
halo techs and you could see that there
was also very good agreement between the
ampliseq and the and the halo clerks
essay with the correlation value of
point 92 so even though that the number
of reads overall or the coverage is not
is relatively low compared to the
targeted panel we still got a very good
correlation with that targeted
test so how do we do this test this test
this essay it's actually this slide
shows you a schematic view of exact one
essay and how it's done here so slides
are first assessed by a pathologist for
neoplastic content and the tumor tissue
is mark and marco defected
DNA from the SSP tumor tissue and match
normal control are both extracted
libraries are then toy paired with the
hello clerks technologies as described
before
followed by onboard cluster generation
and the sequencing on the Illumina hi-c
2500 Perl and which are then aligned to
the human genome and the variant calls
are made and the variants are annotated
and classified by our internally
developed in traumatic dark lines using
publicly available as well as our own
developed knowledge base and then the
case is reviewed and the results are
interpreted by molecular pathologists
for signing out in the earlier system
and finally a report is generated and
there is dispensed to the medical
records so this is the probably most of
you know all of you know this is the
sample output from the Machine and the
rescue format and the analysis is the
phone dial up by our LTM analysis
pipeline and there are several phases to
that the first phase of the analogies
includes alignment with the air PW a
night and I know they are followed by
gatk analysis for basic recalibration
realignment around indle and the
generation of say quality score this is
done independently on the tumor and on
the normal samples in the second step
and there is all those steps that have
done now on just on the tumor including
estimation of tumor purity by clone 8
valiant calling and
prioritization of mutation by
actionability
now there is really a third if I can
call it like this a third step which is
the interpretation step and when looking
at these previous steps which including
the technical part of running the essay
the bioinformatics part of the pipeline
the bioinformatics that seems to be
really the most time consuming now in
terms of what it takes in terms of doing
it and the reason is because we
constantly have to write new
interpretation so new finding whether
those are new mutations or whether those
are new samples that we did not see
before with new mutations so to address
that issue of a good number of mutations
and tissues and interpretation we have
developed a knowledge base and this is
what you could see and this knowledge
base allows automation of the
interpretation and saving all our
interpretations here and it allows quick
sort of the interpretation by mutations
and by other search criteria it's also
linked with publicly available databases
including cosmics and others and by now
we have over 200 or 300 interpretations
in these databases this database is also
associated with the Siebel portal that
allows you to look not just at mutations
by also at clinical studies and the
finally based after that step an
automated report is being generated so
our criteria for reporting the results
are based on clinical clinical
actionability and results are reported
in Cerritos so till 1 will be the
clinical actionable mutations those are
typically associated with known FDA and
therapy tio2
those are other genetic alteration in
other console genes and those are really
the cosmic genes but by now there are
over 550 cosmic genes in there in the
database until stories are really
anything else of unknown significance in
other genes and I also provide you hear
the and then the interpretations events
as I notice as I noted to you are Don
for our in-house knowledge base and this
is what our report looks like
each report includes the entire mutation
content divided into the tools and
interpretation as I noted to you the
report also includes sample and NT Phi
of sample type and other diagnoses
histology and other information and it
we also report the overall QC metrics
such as number of weight and average
coverage and as you can see here we also
have an appendix and the appendix
includes all the copy number alteration
profiles by chromosome as well as ICD
automatic screenshot for each mutation
detection and if we want to look at
specific regions you know like you could
see here meek amplification another we
can do that and we can basically zoom in
specific genes and this for example
shows you an eejit EGFR amplification in
a GBM and this pattern will you see all
those spots in the middle amplifying
zone log to ratio of five with one probe
here on the bottom suggest these three
variants deletion within the EGF
amplification region which by now we are
to live in couple of times so we're
finally using this test we have analyzed
and cover
there lies the spectrum of mutation in
our cohort of consultations which is
compromised of say wide range of tumors
we have human blood or planes and a few
other states and this shows you that
results of that analysis as you can see
overall we have identified 40
significant mutations in 1501 genes and
over 300 mutations in po2 in 150 382
genes the most common mutations in our
time in our population of of councils
will pics we see a chaos and kit while
the most common mutated genes into your
to where p53 and APC and based on the
types of tumors that we have analyzed
this that we have analyzed here this is
basically in agreement with the
literature you could see that health we
increased to tear through there are now
over 8,000 genes with above 18,000
unique variants so that makes everything
very very difficult so focusing on the
cancer genes is really there is the
easiest approach
so in summary while Weiss is widely used
in clinical genetics it is only recently
that it started gaining adoption for
cancer care a integration of Weiss into
precision concentrate has leg behind
primarily due to challenges that were
not previously addressed and validated
in the research led and because this is
well all the initial studies have been
done so we have recently developed and
we expect Department of Health approved
clinical exome console tests
version 1 also exact one which can be
used for simultaneous detection of
somatic sniffs in girls and copy number
alteration extensive validation that we
did demonstrated ethics were exact one
is an accurate and reasonably sensitive
test so identifying actionable mutation
and this validation can serve as a
paradigm for future types of validation
and guidelines that may be also required
by the FDA so these are the
acknowledgment that was an effort
between among several departments here
huge effort between the Department of
Pathology and the Medicine Institute for
computational biology and our genomic
resources called passivity and thank you
and I will be happy to take questions
Thanks thank you dr. rennet for bringing
that informative presentation to us
before we get started on the
question-and-answer session I want to
remind our audience how they can submit
their questions questions can be
submitted by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to get
to as many of your questions as we have
time for today now our first question on
the 10d asks what is the difference
between whole genome sequencing and
whole exome sequencing yeah so as I
showed before yeah it's really first of
all the target areas the exome is a very
limited in terms of what its target it's
only targeting the xdxd coding gene
coding regions of the genes
it doesn't include for most part it
doesn't include the three prime or five
point translated areas of the gene also
in terms of the splice sites it's only
really extended a few nucleotides out of
the exons so it will not talk
more important changes within the
influence and it does not contain other
regions and for example non-coding DNA
or other type of an imp of of changes
that I mean not sequential it could be
important
also this coverage at this point is
relatively low it's much lower than the
exome at this point
and finally it's really outrageously
expensive I could see down the road when
prices go down that that could be a
great way for genetics also because
overall the whole genome sequencing test
seems to be more unified in terms of
their results they produce compared to
what I showed you today but yeah so
those are some of the principles and but
but as I said the genome does contain
all information so this is a big
advantage great thank you I think and
follow-up to that question which
specific genome sequences are covered by
the whole exome sequencing test and how
it say it again
which specific genome sequences are
covered by the whole oh yeah that's what
I actually that's what I just said that
person that basically the size Prime and
three prime regions are not covered it's
really focusing on the air on the coding
regions of the genes great okay
we have another question how do I access
the wild Cornell medicine knowledge base
so yeah I did provide the on one of the
slides
I did the the URL that database is now I
think as of last month or so really the
last month or two months we it's now
fully available on the web to be used
and there is a URL that can be emailed
for people who are interested I put it
on one of the slides okay thank you
we have an attendee that asks is I p.m.
freely available so what does it mean I
p.m. you mean the database I guess
they're not if they mean the database
here the database it can be accessed
free of charge okay I TM database I
assume that's what they are asking right
I think so
now another question following up can
the database be used for targeted gene
sequence yeah yeah I mean yeah that's
what I was showing that and we basically
took the approach of focusing on five
genes and five mutations from New York
State so you could use you could do
whatever you want I mean there are now
many we targeted there are many targeted
mutations that are a part of many panels
and those will be identified using this
test so the nice thing about this test
is that you could you could use it to
identify hotspots oh and you can use it
as a screening tool okay thank you
that's good information for our
attendees I think that is all the time
we have for questions doctor winner I
just like to pass it back to you and see
if you have any final comments for our
attendees today yeah when I think that
oval
it tastes like that I mean the utility
of a test like that it's really
sometimes test that certain procedures
maybe seem a ahead of time and then
maybe not completely the right things to
do but with the very quick advancement
in medicine and also in technologies
it's really the ability to to be able to
screen for mutation and the ability to
be able to do for example jo9 analogies
at the same time is really a great tool
and I think that once we have new
technologies we just have to try and use
them and push them to the limit because
in a few years from now that would
become the way to do this molecular
diagnosis test
great thank you I wanna thank you again
dr. rennet for bringing this
presentation to us and I want to let our
audience know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through October 2017 you'll receive an
email from lab roots alerting you when
this webcast is available for replay and
we invite you to forward that
announcement to any colleagues who may
have missed today's live event
thank you for logging on and joining us
today we hope we see you again thank you
very much goodbye thank you
you